la réforme des retraites puisque c'est
évidemment l'actualité de la semaine et
Quentin avant d'en parler avec
Jean-Baptiste Arnaud on va faire le
point avec vous on en est où de l'examen
de cette réforme on peut le dire les
débats sont au point mort le député
n'ont pas siégé hier sur la réforme des
retraites puisque la journée était
réservée à des textes du Parti
socialiste alors ils se sont arrêtés
mercredi soir ils en sont toujours à
l'article 1 vous savez celui sur la
suppression de certains régimes spéciaux
comme celui de la RATP des clercs de
notaire ou encore des agents des
industries gazières et d'électricité et
donc on peut le dire à la séance de
mercredi soir a encore été marquée par
des incidents avec un rythme assez
étrange des députés qui débattent la
séance qui semble ronronnée et puis d'un
seul coup des escarmouches dans tous les
sens regardez c'était vers minuit
mercredi soir on a fait un petit montage
chers collègues êtes-vous orgueilleux où
êtes-vous des monstres vous nous parlez
souvent de justice mais que savez-vous
de la justice sociale fiscale écologique
la vie ne se résume pas au travail sous
prétexte qu'il faut travailler pour
vivre alors que le plus important dans
la vie c'est de vivre
nous avons tous la même légitimité et
j'entends que chacun soit respecté
vous en venez maintenant avoir des
discours écrits parce que
vraisemblablement vous manquez tellement
d'imagination qu'il faut que vous
écriviez vous êtes des monstres que vous
écriviez vous faites pitié je ne
laisserai pas passer les insultes envers
les parlementaires de mon groupe
président
et on arrête
de créer
c'est l'exemple typique de l'ambiance
pesante qui règne à certains moments au
Palais Bourbon depuis le début de
l'examen du texte c'était lundi Quentin
l'ambiance particulièrement tendue entre
la majorité présidentielle et la gauche
de l'hémicycle voilà et ce depuis le
début le tout premier jour la nuque a
multiplié les rappels au règlement les
députés du PS des écologistes des
communistes et de la France insoumise
qui ont fait beaucoup de bruit pour
contester l'organisation des débats
autour d'émotions c'était le tout
premier jour empêchant même
rappelez-vous le ministre du Travail de
commencer son discours regardez c'était
donc lundi
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du stop
ministre du Travail du plan d'emploi et
de l'insertion s'il vous plaît
madame la Présidente
[Musique]
y sommes monsieur le ministre on va
suspendre 5 minutes le temps que c'est
un collègue laisse le gouvernement
s'exprimer voilà c'était le tout premier
épisode marquant d'une série autre
épisode cette semaine cette tension
entre la France insoumise et la macronie
celui autour du retour en séance
d'Adrien catenas on va revoir ce moment
on en parle après Oriane le dernier
amendement de cette série qui est
présenté par Monsieur cattenin
merci monsieur le Président
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues
chers collègues ce qui se passe ce soir
ne peut pas être passé sous silence nous
avons eu
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas gagné au tirage
au sort et quand l'un de leurs collègues
qui a été condamné pour
avoir épouse prends la parole sur un
abonnement vous restez stoïque pire que
ça vous applaudissez
scandaleux c'est nous voilà pour
l'ambiance entre la gauche de
l'hémicycle et la République en marche
alors voilà tout ce Brouard on notera la
position du rassemblement national le RN
a bien tenté de faire adopter une motion
référendaire en tout début d'examen
objectif que les Français se prononcent
par oui ou par non sur la réforme mais
vous le voyez que le vote qui s'affiche
à la gauche a refusé de s'allier avec le
RN et n'a pas siéger pendant cette
séance toute la question maintenant
c'est de savoir jusqu'où iront les
députés pour l'heure il reste rien
16216 amendements très précisément à
examiner sur la totalité des
20440 déposés vous voyez le chiffre qui
s'affiche sauf qu'il faut avoir terminé
vendredi soir la semaine prochaine le 17
février à minuit on verra quel sera la
stratégie des oppositions d'ici là
vont-ils continuer l'obstruction ou
tenter d'aller jusqu'à l'article 7 celui
sur la mesure d'âge et les 64 ans
[Musique]
quelques moments d'ambiance est-ce qu'on
peut tenir des débats dans une telle
ambiance sur Baptiste
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
l'interview que Jean-Louis de Bruay nous
accordait hier en disant que des gens
lui écrivent régulièrement en lui disant
à votre époque c'était mieux et il
répond vous avez la mémoire courte en
fait ce qu'on voit c'est que tous les
trois ou quatre ans il y a un grand
projet de loi qui divise beaucoup que
soit mariage pour tous qu'on a gaucher
au pouvoir ou la loi el khomri la
dernière réforme des retraites quand
c'était plutôt les les macronistes on
voit cette incapacité à débattre à faire
tenir un débat dans le temps qui serait
nécessaire pour le pour le tenir
sereinement donc voilà il y a en soi
rien de nouveau il y a peut-être un côté
un peu plus encore peut-être plus
éruptif avec avec la France insoumise
qui a des méthodes d'être un peu plus un
peu plus rude un peu plus frontale
encore que les oppositions allant à
l'ancienne voilà c'est ce qu'on c'est ce
qu'on redécouvre puisqu'on ne le
découvre tous les trois ou quatre ans
c'est du classique en tout cas pas de
l'inhabituel Arnaud dans un hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale
de l'Assemblée nationale depuis que la
République existe toujours été une
histoire quand même pleine d'ébullition
de convulsion mais c'est vrai que si
vous voulez il y a peut-être une forme
de rupture par rapport à d'autres
législatures parce que on a une
stratégie qui est la stratégie de la
France insoumise qui est une stratégie
comme vous le dites tout à fait frontale
c'est une sorte d'agide propre
permanente dans l'hémicycle ce qui
évidemment crée de la tension dans un
débat qui déjà est un débat tendu au
regard de l'enjeu qui est celui de la
réforme des retraites donc ça c'est
compliqué moi je suis pas choqué par si
vous voulez le déjà dire l'usage du
droit d'amendement d'abord c'est un
droit constitutionnel et on a vu par
contre là en l'occurrence ce sous
d'autres législatures des dépôts
d'amendement beaucoup plus volumineux je
rappelle juste un chiffre 2006 la
privatisation de Gaz de France 130 000
amendements sont déposés la précédente
réforme des retraites qui n'est pas
allée jusqu'au bout 40.000 amendements
déposés donc le problème c'est pas de
temps finalement de la procédure
parlementaire telle qu'il est fait pour
l'opposition c'est plutôt parfois les
comportements individuels d'un certain
nombre de parlementaires qui peuvent
dans un pays qui certes est un pays
régicide la France peuvent éveiller
aussi parfois un vieux fonds
dommage parce que pour une fois que cet
assemblée ressemble à la réalité
politique du pays il serait dommage que
l'opinion publique finalement se
retourne contre une assemblée qui de
fait quand même ressemble politiquement
et sociaux peut-être pas
sociologiquement mais en tout cas
politiquement au pays
le rôle du Parlement de l'image qu'on
les Français du Parlement Jean-Baptiste
après c'est honnêtement c'est une
question assez ouverte c'est toujours
difficile de voir à quel point le grand
public
quelle est l'image que le grand public
perçoit vraiment il y a vous allez avoir
des gens assez politisés qui sont sur
les réseaux sociaux qui vont dans une
bulle cognitive où il ne voit que les
contenus des personnalités dont ils sont
proches politiquement donc ça les
confirme dans leur ça les confirme dans
leur biais tout ça c'est vraiment qu'un
murmure pour le grand public à la limite
ils vont voir avoir une image un peu
comme ça irruptive pas très à la hauteur
vous aurez tous les présidents de
l'Assemblée qui diront toujours que les
gens leur écrivent pour leur dire que
vraiment ce qu'ils voient et pas du tout
pas du tout à la hauteur les présidents
de l'Assemblée lisent à chaque fois en
début de séance vraiment les Français
nous regardent tenez vous
ça change rien alors il reste 6 jours
d'examens puisque Quentin le rappelait
ça dort
la question c'est que là on est encore à
l'article il y a l'article 7 qu'on
tiendrater qui est le l'article qui
reporte l'âge de départ quel peut être
la stratégie de la gaucher est-ce que
ils ont intérêt à ce que cet article
soit examiné parce que c'est là qu'on va
avoir un peu quels sont précisément les
positions ou est-ce qu'ils ont intérêt à
ce que le débat ne se fasse pas alors il
y a un élément de langage commun et il y
a un mystère à côté l'élément de langage
commun c'est on dépose plein
d'amendements parce que comme ça ça nous
permettra de les retirer peut-être par
bloc 2000 et puis comme ça on arrivera
plus vite à un point qui met en danger
la majorité on va aller surprendre il y
a le côté un peu gardénère donc ça c'est
l'élément de langage un peu commun qui
permet de mettre la majorité sous
tension et donner l'impression que la
gauche est en maîtrise la question c'est
est-ce qu'ils sont d'accord entre eux
déjà ne serait-ce quand on voit le
nombre d'amendements déposés on voit que
la France insoumise est près de près de
12000 les écologistes les socialistes et
les communistes une opposition beaucoup
plus constructive donc c'est beaucoup
moins au sein même de la France
insoumise vous avez des François ruffins
des clémentines hautains qui disent
attention il faut quand même prendre du
fond il faut pas qu'on donne cette image
là et vous en avez d'autres qui sont
dans une opposition comme on avait vu en
2020 sur la précédente réforme des
retraites beaucoup plus frontale
beaucoup plus brute de décoffrage donc
même entre eux ils sont pas
nécessairement d'accord donc ce qui va
être intéressant c'est de voir la
semaine prochaine et ce qu'ils arrivent
vraiment à se discipliner collectivement
pour essayer de surprendre la majorité
auquel cas ça veut dire que la stratégie
qu'ils avaient annoncé ce ce confirme ou
est-ce qu'ils seront dans l'incapacité
puisque certains individus comme le
disaient Arnaud tout à l'heure
finalement on sombre un truc un peu
juste jusqu'au boutiste et auquel cas
collectivement ils sont incapable de
tenir sa stratégie donc ça c'est on sera
la semaine prochaine ça va être ça de la
semaine prochaine quelle stratégie de la
gauche et comment vont-ils avoir la
maîtriser parce que c'est vrai qu'avec
ces amendements ils ont quelque part un
peu la maîtrise du temps la maîtrise du
temps qui comptait quand même du fait de
la procédure qui a été adoptée par le
gouvernement pour la discussion de ce
texte à l'Assemblée nationale procédure
assez inédite quand même il faut le il
faut le noter donc ça va être compliqué
moi je pense que quand même la stratégie
de fond c'est il me semble je peux me
tromper on s'est souvent trompé
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence donc il faut
être très prudent mais la stratégie de
fond c'est peut-être de pousser le
gouvernement à essayer d'adopter une
stratégie qui est une stratégie de
passage en force le moment venu
c'est-à-dire de rajouter finalement gère
cette ce sentiment déjà de brutalité qui
un taureau à raison qui en tout cas est
dénoncé par les oppositions et par les
syndicats une brutalité parlementaire
c'est-à-dire en fait on va jusqu'au bout
ils vont être obligés d'utiliser un
moment donné le 44 3 pour montrer
regarder cette réforme finalement le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu négocier avec
les part réseaux sociaux il ne veut pas
négocier avec les parlementaires il a la
rue contre lui il a l'opinion contre lui
il veut absolument passer en force je
pense qu'il y a quand même aussi cette
idée qui doit animer un certain nombre
de parlementaires notamment de la France
insoumise en disant que de toute façon à
un moment donné on y reviendra peut-être
après la question ça va se jouer entre
la rue et le gouvernement donc c'est ça
le vrai sujet après pour le gouvernement
en effet
il faut tout faire pour éviter d'avoir
recours aux 49-3 parce que là ça serait
un très mauvais signal qui serait envoyé
notamment notamment même au groupe
parlementaire d'opposition je pense au
LR qui sont censés soutenir le
gouvernement et qui ne sont pas
favorables parce que l'on passe par le
49-3 pour affaire adopter cette réforme
sachant qu'en plus il y a des objectifs
intermédiaires c'est pas forcément
pousser le gouvernement en 49-3 ou rien
c'est aussi par exemple le faire en
sorte que l'article 7 ne soit jamais
adopté parce que l'article 7 c'est
l'article qui recule de 62 à 64 ans à
l'âge légal c'est aussi un objectif de
de la gauche de faire en sorte que
jamais la représentation nationale n'est
votée cet article et que finalement
c'est peut-être pareil puissement du
temps que le projet de loi est transmis
au Sénat mais pas parce qu'il y a eu un
vote ouais effectivement ce sont deux
stratégies différentes hein qu'on va
suivre et alors l'exécutif est monté
hier soir et cette nuit au créneau pour
défendre sa réforme et alors qu'on est
on vous le disiez à la veille d'une
nouvelle journée de mondialisation va
d'abord écouter Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel
Macron cette nuit à Bruxelles il a
appelé les syndicats à la responsabilité
et ensuite
des manifestations et des mouvements de
grève qui continueront de s'organiser
dans un cadre qui est prévu par la
Constitution et je sais pouvoir compter
sur l'esprit de responsabilité de leurs
organisateurs pour que la contestation
est les désaccords puissent s'exprimer
mais dans le calme le respect des biens
et des personnes et avec une volonté de
ne pas bloquer la vie du reste du pays
alors voilà pour Emmanuel Macron et ce
matin Elisabeth borne dans la voie du
Nord et bien elle répond au lecteur ça
fait la ligne nous n'avons pas le choix
pour sauver notre système c'est ce que
dit la première ministre effectivement à
ses lecteurs rencontré hier à organiser
à la préfecture de Lille la première
ministre s'est montré plus déterminée
que jamais à aller au bout de son projet
écrit le journal Elisabeth borne par
exemple qui se dit choqué d'entendre que
la réforme pénalise les femmes et de
plaider en faveur d'un changement de
regard sur les seniors en entreprise on
retient aussi cet échange avec avec un
lecteur comment vivez-vous le fait de
porter une réforme qui rallonge le temps
de travail alors que vous faites partie
des privilégiés demande un français venu
interroger interroger Isabelle borne
elle répond ce n'est pas par plaisir
qu'on demande aux Français de travailler
plus longtemps et de défendre le système
par répartition mise en danger par
l'évolution de la démocratie démographie
française mais alors pourquoi ne pas
chercher d'autres moyens de financement
la première ministre explique alors que
le taux d'imposition en France et parmi
les plus élevés au monde et un peu plus
tard dans les échanges elle redit ne pas
vouloir alourdir les taxes car cela
détruit des emplois
et tombe toujours de convaincre et de
faire de la pédagogie sur sa réforme à
la veille d'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation est-ce qu'ils peuvent tenir
ce qu'on voit c'est déjà dans cette
interview de Elisabeth borne ce qu'on
entend aussi depuis plusieurs semaines
c'est que quelque part la fable de la
réforme juste de progrès on l'entend
plus maintenant tout si vous disent
voilà on assume de demander un effort
aux Français on sait que c'est pas
facile
qui disent que finalement c'est le moins
mauvais argument pour pour faire passer
la réforme avec l'idée que si les
Français sont opposés très
majoritairement à leurs réformes il y a
toujours environ 50% des français qui se
dit qu'ils se disent favorables à une
réforme des retraites sous-entendu que
il y aurait la moitié des Français qui
ont intégré qu'il faut quand même faire
quelque chose donc c'est plus plutôt
là-dessus qui qui compte ensuite est-ce
qu'ils vont venir dans l'immédiat il y a
rien qui leur fait peur finalement les
mobilisations sont assez favorables
favorables pardon assez comparable à ce
qui se passait en 2010 et le ministre du
Travail de l'époque Éric verdt qui est
désormais député Renaissance dit souvent
que en réalité dans ces cas là faut pas
donner l'impression de céder ou de
négocier parce que sinon c'est un signe
de faiblesse que vous envoyez et vous et
le bar vous renforcer vous renforcer la
rue eux ils sont dans une position de
dire on conserte on écoute en réalité
des coupes pas grand chose mais ils
disent qu'il concerne et puis ils
gardent leur CAP pour l'instant il y a
absolument rien qui les fait dévier
il y a deux hypothèses soit c'est 2010
soit c'est 1995 en fin de compte 2010 en
effet c'est l'hypothèse favorable
c'est-à-dire malgré les mobilisations le
texte est adopté et finalement l'opinion
publique finit par accepter ce texte
c'est le pari qui est fait par
l'exécutif l'autre hypothèse c'est
l'hypothèse finalement notamment des
syndicats et notamment de la CGT c'est
de considérer que il faut instaurer un
rapport de force qui permette d'arriver
à une situation qui fut celle de 1995
c'est-à-dire un retrait de l'iPhone mais
pour se faire il va falloir bloquer un
moment donné parce que 1995 c'est comme
ça que ça a fonctionné c'est que vous
avez eu un mouvement social avec des
blocages et surtout ce qu'on a appelé à
l'époque une grève par procuration
c'est-à-dire le soutien de l'opinion
publique à ce mouvement de grève est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'opinion publique qui
soutient les mobilisations est prête à
soutenir j'allais dire des blocages sur
la durée ça c'est une autre question
pour le moment on voit bien que quand
même la stratégie des syndicats la
stratégie j'allais dire du front
syndical c'est certes d'utiliser la
grève et les blocages mais de manière
j'allais dire très par simonieuse on va
voir si sur la durée ils vont disons
intensifier cette stratégie ou pas et le
vrai sujet c'est qu'ensuite pour
l'instant si vous voulez les syndicats
sont d'accord sur l'objectif c'est à
dire faire reculer le gouvernement mais
ils ne sont pas forcément d'accord sur
la durée sur les moyens d'action qui
vont mettre en place pour faire plier le
gouvernement et évidemment on peut
imaginer que du côté de l'exécutif on
parie sur ces divergences d'appréciation
compte au moyen pour d'une certaine
manière commencer à fissurer l'unité
syndicale juste un point sur la
communication moi je pense que sur la
communication en effet l'exécutif depuis
le début n'arrive pas à stabiliser sa
communication il y a un principe de base
en communication qui était un principe
publicitaire qui avait été inventé par
la publicité américaine qui s'appelle
rosseries il disait ce qu'il appelait
l'unique proposition de vente il disait
quand vous avez un produit et quand vous
avez un produit qui s'agisse d'une
politique publique ou d'un produit il
faut toujours avoir le même message et
un message et de répéter tout le temps
là vous avez un gouvernement qui a
justifié sa réforme des retraites avec
différents messages qui devient
totalement inaudibles pour l'opinion
publique moi je pense fondamentalement
donné Macron a dit cette réforme elle
était nécessaire pour financer d'autres
politiques publiques
cette réforme c'était une réforme de
justice sociale en effet on a du mal à
certains ont du mal à s'y retrouver dans
le motif de réformes de justice sociale
et puis maintenant on nous dit non il
faut sauver à absolument le régime par
répartition donc si vous voulez tout
cela en l'occurrence ça devient
finalement assez inédit pour l'opinion
publique et ça ne sécurise pas le texte
qui est présenté ainsi par le
gouvernement donc je pense que c'est un
vrai sujet à vrai problème et la
bataille de l'opinion quand le veuille
non ils peuvent parler de pédagogie de
pédagogie de pédagogie mais il faut
arrêter de penser que les Français sont
totalement idiots en l'occurrence en
tout cas il y en a un certain nombre qui
ont compris ce qu'il y avait derrière
cette réforme qui ont compris et qui la
justifie qui ont compris et qu'ici
oppose mais je veux dire c'est pas un
problème de pédagogie en l'occurrence
oui juste un mot sur les la stratégie
des syndicats puisque on était
effectivement dans les cortèges mardi et
qu'on voyait qu'effectivement pour
l'instant l'idée c'était bien de
rassembler dans la rue y compris avec
cette la mobilisation de ce week-end ou
voilà la cfdtv un grand rassemblement
familial et populaire et quelque chose
de très positif mais envoyer que c'est
donc le mot d'ordre qui était général
mais vous voyez que certaines centrales
forces ouvrière ou la CGT était presque
impatient un moment de dire ok cette
stratégie ne n'a pas fonctionné donc
retour à notre méthode c'est-à-dire des
grèves des blocages des choses qui
impactent davantage encore plus que que
ces mobilisations dans la rue et on voit
que c'est comme ça aussi quelque chose
qui va se jouer parmi les syndicats et
puis ce qui peut être intéressant de
voir demain c'est combien de personnes
sont sont dans la rue parce que un
samedi c'est pas nécessaire de perdre
une journée de salaire pour aller
manifester donc ça donnera une idée
aussi de finalement gratuitement combien
de personnes sont prêtes à aller à aller
manifester et ça donnera une idée un peu
de vraiment de de l'europosition à la
réforme parce que quand on fait le
comparatif avec d'autres époques faut
voir aussi que tout le monde aura
actuellement on est dans une période de
crise de pouvoir d'achat de crise de
l'inflation c'est pas parce que vous
êtes pas capable financièrement de vous
permettre de poser une journée une
journée de grève que vous n'êtes pas en
colère et que votre colère vous la ferez
pas payer autrement donc vraiment cette
journée de demain elle va être
intéressante parce qu'elle va donner
quand même une image un peu du d'un
autre rapport de force qu'on n'aura pas
vu sur les sur les précédentes de
journées effectivement il y a la
question du rapport de force et est-ce
que selon le chiffre de la mobilisation
demain il y a de notre journée qui est
prévue jeudi juste avant la fin de
l'examen du texte est-ce que ça ça peut
être aussi un moyen de pression sur les
parlementaires est-ce que ça peut faire
changer d'avis certains parlementaires
il est clair que ça aussi c'est le pari
des syndicats le pari des syndicats
c'est de dire que finalement ce qui se
passe dans l'immobilisation va finir par
avoir un impact sur le Parlement
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas un lieu
qui est complètement j'allais dire
étanche par rapport au reste de la
société donc les parlementaires ils
descendent dans leur circonscription le
week-end ils entendent leurs électeurs
et leurs et leurs électrices qui pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux sont opposés
à cette réforme donc ça peut avoir un
impact ça peut avoir surtout un impact
sur les parlementaires j'allais dire à
la fois qui à l'intérieur de la majorité
ont exprimé un certain nombre de doutes
c'est-à-dire plutôt l'aile gauche de la
de la de la de la majorité mais aussi
sur les parlementaires dont on voit
quand même que le vote homogène n'est
pas du tout assuré pour l'instant à ce
stade sur cette sur cette réforme donc
en effet pour les parlementaires qui
sont j'allais dire les plus qui sont les
plus en doutes ça peut avoir un effet et
comme on est surtout dans une dans une
arithmétique parlementaire avec une
majorité très relative en effet les
mobilisations ont encore plus de poids
parce que tout simplement la
configuration de l'Assemblée fait que le
poids des mobilisations il va finir par
il peut impacter alors c'est tout à fait
vrai et en même temps on voit que pour
l'instant le film se déroule quand même
globalement comme prévu pour pour le
gouvernement dans le sens où les
parlementaires estampillés aile gauche
une à gauche quand même très très
modérée de de renaissance globalement
sont en train de rentrer dans le rang
ils sont là ils votent donc il pas
tellement de problèmes ou d'inconnus de
ce point de vue là et quelque part le
fait qu'il y a une cohésion de la
majorité fait aussi qu'il y a pas il y a
pas vraiment de brèches donc il y a pas
non plus tellement de raisons que pour
l'instant le fait de se faire engueuler
individuellement fait que ça aboutit à
une forme de détection individuelle à
Paris qui pourrait ensuite devenir une
détection d'un petit groupe pour
l'instant globalement ça tient pour eux
pour la majorité est-ce
que la clé c'est aussi les républicains
est-ce que là chez les républicains ça
peut aussi expliquer les divisions qu'il
y a le poids de la rue le retour des
gens c'est que les LR vont pas avoir le
désavantage dans dossier la popularité
d'une réforme sans avoir l'avantage
quelque part d'exercer le pouvoir donc
il y a cette réticence qu'on peut
comprendre cela étant encore une fois
quand on voit que l'article liminaire du
projet de loi le seul qui a été adopté
pour l'instant l'a été alors qu'en
commission il avait été quand même très
très vidé sa substance c'est aussi parce
que il y a eu suffisamment de voix du
côté de LR pour pour le voter donc là
encore pour l'instant ça semble ça
semble tenir et voilà certains projets
présidents hier disaient que dans les
pointages qui sont faits pour l'instant
ils sont pas trop inquiets alors ça peut
bouger mais ils sont pas inquiets pour
l'instant on suivra tout ça
[Musique]